[Musique]
ici à Tours battlekart c'est un peu
comme un jeu vidéo de course mais dans
la vraie vie alors sauf qu'ici on ne
jette pas des bananes ni des champignons
mais c'est bien bouclier de protection
mitraillette G2 plaques d'huile tu peux
interagir avec le décor pour provoquer
des situations glissantes l'objectif est
de faire le plus de tours possible avant
le gong final alors bienvenue à
battlekart entre karting et jeux vidéo
et surtout ne soyez pas mauvais perdant
vous ordinateur
Free
c'est parti mon kiki
bouton jaune
[Musique]
formidable du Battle kart là c'est
incroyable ce truc et bah l'idée d'un
jeune Belge ingénieur qui a qui a créé
battlekart il y a une quinzaine d'années
et qu'il a développé qui l'a conçu de A
à Z et aujourd'hui qu'il propose en
franchise bon alors qui vient ici c'est
des jeunes c'est ça qui est cool avec
battle card notre corps c'est une
grand-mère qui avait 85 ans qui a joué
ici c'est pas vrai si elle est venue
jouer avec ses enfants et ses
petits-enfants le truc qui est génial ce
chien à le dire c'est qu'on se sent
vachement en sécurité c'est le système
anti-collision Sébastien a développé ce
qui nous permet de jouer sans casque
mais alors le principe du jeu parce que
moi je t'avoue je suis pas un
spécialiste
des jeux vidéo comment ça fonctionne
concrètement en fait il y a des capteurs
d'installer au plafond d'accord qui
permettent de localiser des kartings sur
la piste et puis après bah comme le
karting est localisé quand il passe sur
une case bonus il sait qu'il passe sur
une case bonus il nous fait gagner un
bonus qui apparaît à l'écran il nous
reste plus qu'à appuyer sur un bouton
qui est dédié sur le volant pour
déclencher le bonus si tu as gagné un
missile tu appuies sur le bouton tu as
un missile comme tu as pu voir qui sort
comme par magie de ton karting qui trace
tout droit si tu as bien visé ce qui a
pas été trop tonton
si tu as bien visé bah celui-ci il
croise un autre karting il va exploser
et il va arrêter le karting qui l'a
touché Nicolas est-ce qu'on peut dire
que tu es un grand enfant oui oui
complètement moi j'ai été élevé dans ce
milieu là j'ai été visé dans le milieu
du sport automobile on se refait une
partie Camille je suis chaud c'est parti
let's go
rouge et bleu à rouge et bleu
on est serré dans un mouchoir de poche
camion de jeunes positions
[Musique]
ça se joue dans un mouchoir de poche ils
sont déterminés 5 minutes
il va le faire oui oui
Game Over Kamini ça fait trois heures
que tu es là tu as perdu tu as perdu
là je pense que je dois refaire une
dernière partie alors je sais tu vas te
dire je suis accro ça n'a rien à voir
c'est je suis pas accro mais juste c'est
juste une dernière partie histoire de
bien comprendre la mécanique j'ai des
clients qui attendent là j'ai encore un
tour à faire messieurs dames voilà
quelques
un dernier tour quoi